hello folks and welcome back to the show
that lets artistic endeavors don suits
of armor and duke it out for artistic
supremacy
today on the show it's a royal righteous
rich guy wrestle fest between batman
and iron man both accomplished prime
fighters with
wonderful toys but only one can be
crowned the best of the billionaire
badasses
tony stark the jet setting playboy who
went from manufacturing weapons to
battling against them
versus bruce wayne the ultimate trust
fund kid who grew up to be more than a
man but a symbol
mistakes are high as the winner gets to
spike superman's alcohol spritzer
with kryptonite i love it here's how
we'll get there
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score
round three competition and then we'll
do a wild card round that bruce wayne
hopes doesn't involve
cool facial hair hey both these guys
have great butlers tons of money and can
stay up as late as they want
let's get it on what are your
superpowers again
genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist
i'm rich round one box office
who amongst us hasn't seen a batman or
an iron man
in a movie theater it's not a question
of if you've seen one it's simply a
matter of which movie was your first
and what character were you dressed up
as at the time
of the people in this room which one is
a wearing a spangly outfit and b
not a fuse for me i cosplayed as a
chubby eight-year-old
to batman 1989 the whole family made the
trip to see the new talking picture that
would dominate that summer
since then i've seen the good the bad
and the ugly when it comes to both bats
and iron man
and clearly i was not the only one
to date films featuring batman in a
prominent role sorry suicide squad
have grossed a total of 4.27 billion
dollars domestically and 8.65 billion
across the globe
that's tossing in all the batman flicks
the dc eu movies the lego features
and the animated flicks mask of the
phantasm and the killing joke
all told batman averages 619 million
dollars worldwide every time he washes
his tights
that's super impressive because more
often than not he's shouldering the load
that's not always the case with his
combatant iron man
this is why superman works alone yes
tony stark does just fine on his own
thank you very much
but that mcu is a cash cow with gold and
udders
if we add up all the films that give
iron man a meaty chunk of screen time
it equals 4.82 billion dollars
domestically and 12.9 billion worldwide
wow all that money and kevin feige still
dresses like me
going to the sadie hawkins dance iron
man relies heavily on his numerous
avenger pals to average 1.44
billion dollars per movie worldwide so
that's no contest
but what if we look at the just iron man
lead movies versus batman
led movies let's take a look at the most
celebrated trilogies in each crime
fighters blu
ray collection the dark knight from
christopher nolan
and the first three iron man films from
john favreau and
shane black christian bale defeats
robert downey jr here in both domestic
and worldwide totals with a dark knight
doing
3.16 billion dollars worth of
international business
to iron man's 2.85 billion dollar total
ironman is no doubt one of the if not
the most important part of the marvel
cinematic universe
after all without his first movie in
2008 we might not have the mcu and
instead we'd be arguing about which
extraordinary gentleman is the most
extra in the league but he does have a
ton of help captain america
spider-man black panther black widow
that kid who he met
in tennessee over christmas that's not
to say batman didn't get help but his
best assistance
is arguably who he was going up against
i doubt batman 1989 or the dark knight
would have been the sensations they are
without jack and heath respectively but
when a universe needs a boost
batman is the first number you call or
you put up the
signal instead of being patient and
giving superman a sequel the dceu just
threw batman in there instead
look he's in the title see the movie and
the lego movie saw he was so valuable
they gave him his own lego movie
iron man is the richer billionaire at
the box office but per penny worth
no one hero is more valuable than the
caped crusader
i mean there's a reason he got that
title knuckles batman
you win round one and you're up one
nothing it's not who i am underneath
but what i do that defines me
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
wayne enterprises has an early lead over
stark industries but the long-term
success of any corporation is predicated
upon making your customers happy
and although the ending of most batman
iron man films involves cities being
decimated
we all usually walk out of the theater
pretty satisfied
audiences not only show up in droves to
see these two fellows they also rate
them pretty high with the rotten
tomatoes
audience score iron man has been a crowd
pleaser ever since black sabbath wrote
the song in the 70s
it's the movie came out in 2008 and it
still ranks as the high mark for tony
stark
that the avengers and avengers end game
are all
tied with a 91 audience score even
better news is that the lowest rated
iron man flick is iron man 2
at 71 if you gave me a 71 on a
trigonometry test i'd say
sold hello yale thanks for pep talk
percent
the average audience score for all iron
man centric cinema is 86
which outpaces that bat guy considerably
overall batmani movies average a 71
audience score which again equals iron
man's all-time weakest film
batman certainly has horsepower with
moviegoers as evidenced by both
batman begins and the dark knights score
but man has that guy and his nipples
made some bad movies
batman and robin the low point for comic
book movies and society in general
only nabbed 16 percent from audiences
stay cool batman forever and the killing
joke also weighed down
gotham's audience score critics
similarly had plenty of venom towards
the val kilmer george clooney era
as batman forever has a 39 and batman
and robin only mustered 11
on the tomato meter but at least this
also gives us an excuse to give props to
some of the animated batman endeavors
mask of the phantasm is a very fresh 84
percent
and the original lego movie is the
freshest of all batman related films at
96
that's good enough to top anything iron
man has done relax everybody i'm here
batman his highest output on the tomato
meter is iron man and avengers end game
both at 94 percent
for funsies the dark knight also 94
overall iron man may have an on-again
off-again relationship with pepper potts
but the critics have always loved him
his movies average an impressive 86
percent on the tomato meter
while batman and his many at bats
pun average is still fresh 67.2 percent
i don't remember every beat of iron man
2 and i'm not going to defend the hill
on which the mandarin switcheroo lives
but i will say nothing in the mcu has
ever been as close to stinky
as the smattering of duds batman has
given us over the years
as the legendary christmas tune goes
robin laid an egg
and now iron man can claim his first
victory in this match
tony stark takes the round and we're
tied at one a piece
i'm the best round three competition
oh what a fun round this is gonna be
sure when we say competition we're
referencing
the villains that these two rich kids
had to battle
but it doesn't end there batman and iron
man are also competing against each
other
with all of their cool gadgets is a is a
car
gadget yep all right game on
chicks dig the car as far back as 1966
batman has been on the silver screen
giving all of us toys to be jealous of
from that classic batmobile to the back
copter and of course shark spray
adam west's batman gave all other gotham
knights big boots to fill
boots that would eventually be upgraded
to ice skates
michael keaton added the batarang
grapple gun and a cool
car siri feature shield then kevin
conroy's animated batman perfected the
art of the smoke bomb
christian bale's bat tech became so
advanced we could track every citizen in
gotham
from their cell phone and then batfleck
blessed us all with a suit designed to
fight evil aliens
i don't care if that flying dude claims
he's from kansas he's a martian
and he needs to be grounded regardless
of your favorite batman over the decades
we can all agree the car dude drives has
always been
legit the convertible was street legal
the tumbler was
utilitarian and the batman returns one
perfected a 360 turn that all but
eliminated blind spots
however while alfred was putting the
second coat of wax on his boss's main
form of transportation
iron man's best vehicle was um
himself mostly derived from necessity
with a touch of ego
tony stark implanted tech inside himself
ever since he was trapped in a cave
he learned that a marriage of body and
technology is essential to fighting
crime
when you have billions of dollars to
spend you can get multiple versions of
everything
get this he has 50 different versions of
the iron man suit
i'd be happy with one like i'd even time
share it with four of my friends
oh yeah that's awesome give me a suit
okay
oh i'm sorry they're only coded to me
what does that mean iron man is no
slouch when it comes to weapons and
gadgets either
and no i'm not talking about the jericho
missile i might however be referencing
the portable full-service bar that he
totes around
ask your wiver if that thing's a weapon
he's also got the classic tank missile
complete with a cool
walk away he must have practiced in the
mirror and stark
even invented a new element
appropriately called badassium
you see kids chemistry can be fun
yes science but it all boils down to who
are you going up against with all this
awesome technology
batman hands down has faced a better
roster of villains than iron man
or at least they're more memorable i
like obadiah stain and loki
and justin hammer but come on does your
grandpa know who they are
unless your grandpa is michael douglas
but even my great-grandfather who played
pro ball for a few seasons with the
white sox that's true
he knew about the joker the riddler
catwoman
penguin bane maybe not bang
impossible but you get the idea batman
should win this villain tussle easy if
not
for the most feared purple antagonist of
adults
since barney thanos shows up and it's a
whole new ball game he could throw a
moon at you
and with the snap of his fingers he can
wipe out half of existence
we needed every ounce of tony stark and
company to defeat that guy
so that does score major points in my
book when it all comes down to it we're
comparing two different
arrows of crime fighter should batman
lose points because
morgan freeman in a basement couldn't
drum up a
spider suit with nanotechnology perhaps
or maybe bruce should gain points for
developing his stuff
decades before tony stark if iron man
went swimming and bruce the shark shows
up
is he prepared to handle it i i don't
know
thanos posed the biggest threat humanity
has ever seen but after that it's a
steep drop off to the next most
threatening baddie
as a matter of fact the second toughest
opponent of iron man's career
it's probably captain america he's my
friend
so was i batman also had to face down a
fellow hero
and he had the game one against superman
if only they both didn't have moms named
after martha washington
why did you say that top to bottom
batman had stiffer competition
and had to go it alone more often than
iron man so even though stark
elevated superhero technology to new
intergalactic heights
batman wins the round for setting the
precedent a light up the bat signal
because vicki vale's crush
just went up two to get one
come on let's get nuts and now it's time
for the wild card round
alter ego so we love us our crime
fighters whether they're battling in
capes
metal suits or hockey pads but what
about the man
under the spandex bruce wayne or tony
stark
if the question is simply who'd you
rather hang with it's an easy win for
tony
guy's got a great place in malibu he
freely gives out the address to anyone
and he's a party animal with kick-ass
taste in music
give me a fat beat to beat my body bruce
is a boring recluse who hangs with his
butler
goes on a date once every decade and
only shows up to events to give the
illusion
that he's a fun playboy too he basically
has to act like tony stark
just to throw gotham's evil underbelly
off his scent
oh a guy dresses up like a bat clearly
has
issues but wayne does have qualities he
inherited a strong sense of community
and philanthropy from his old man
and he also got a boatload of cash from
him never leave the cave without him
and sweet alfred you may not see much of
bruce if you pop by wayne manor for a
visit but alf
he's gonna make sure you're well fed
your glass is full and if you play the
right keys on the piano
you win a tour of the bat cave and
although bruce wears his darkness more
on his sleeve
both richie riches have tons of issues
stemming from the untimely death of
their parents
tony stark was a rebellious genius when
his parents ate it
and although he was a fully grown boy by
the time bucky went
cuckoo for cocoa puffs and off the rents
his last words to his father
were regrettable meanwhile bruce never
even got to have the talk with his dad
he was still running around in his the
phantom underoos when tommy and martha
made that fateful decision to go on
fandango and buy
premium opera tickets remember folks
vote mark l
is for employee of the month they both
drift back to their last few
interactions with their elders on a
regular basis
and it fuels them with a passion to
continue battling the worst scum the
city
or the galaxy has to offer you have
learned to bury your guilt with anger
i will teach you to confront it but tony
stark's parties are legendary
i'm giving him the alter ego round not
just because i want to hang with him and
his cool friends
it's because he knows when to lead and
when to take a back seat
sometimes iron man has to fly first into
the fight in other instances
captain america's job is to lead tony
just has to pay for
everything and make it look cool like
the old man said
together he owns his mistakes like that
time he tried to put a suit of armor
around the world
and he learns from his troubled past
bruce wayne is a great haunted
tortured individual and as hard as he
works to protect his home city
he doesn't play nearly as many away
games as his marvelous counterpart
and again watch the party scene from age
of ultron and tell me that wouldn't be
the best
day of your life imagine how many
instagram likes you get
blessed tony stark wins the alter ego
round
and we're all tied up at two
never one to shrink from an honest
challenge which means i
mark ellis in boy of the month now have
to make the toughest decision of my
versus career
while i consternate through these two
gems one last time
i'll regale you with other hard choices
that i've bravely made on this show star
wars prequels versus sequels
de niro versus pacino godzilla versus
king kong
okay i'll be honest i knew kong was my
guy the whole time
but here it comes down to legacy
batman's started long before iron man
but iron man has since proven himself to
be both a fearsome solo superhero
and a valuable teammate he uses his
brain to further technology for the
cause of justice
and he rightly defers when he's out of
his milky way jurisdiction
tony stark learned from his past and
became a great man
the batman was never really about the
person it was the
symbol that made him more than the
considerable sum of his parts
all that money and ninjutsu and bat
nipples couldn't equal the power of what
the bats stood for
long after bruce sheds his mortal coil
gotham will still be kept in check
by the looming presence of the iconic
batman
batman is my favorite hero of all time
and batman begins is my favorite comic
book flick ever
so why am i giving iron man the win here
[ __ ] because the only thing more
powerful
memorable and inspirational than a
symbol of justice is when a hero
sacrifices themselves for the cause
iron man tony stark finally was at peace
and had a loving family
he was content he didn't pitch in with
the time travel for ego and he didn't
take the snap amongst himself for the
glory
it was the right thing to do he gave his
life for the betterment of humanity
and also that hulkbuster suit it it's
awesome that's just my two pennies and
we're talking about two of the richest
fellows in the entire universe
so now it's your turn dear viewer vote
with your pick in the comment section
right now and cast your ballot with the
same ferocity with which batman yells
the name of his dead girlfriend
love you bats you still my boy blue
is he gone sweet all right
time to gas up the ford fusion and see
who wants to be my plus one to the stark
expo
happy american cheeseburger get in my
belly
got these sunglasses for nine dollars